dreadknot not quiet fight kill live
we hear the communities call for new
content with the April update the live
team is excited to be able to bring new
ways to play an experience destiny
making your guardian more powerful as a
huge component to the destiny experience
so with the April update alive team
raised the light level up to 335 we've
basically made it easier to increase
your light level through different
sources so whatever you're interested in
there's something in there for you
crucible and trials of Osiris and iron
banner core Dvorak's kingsfall nightfall
and prison of elders all roads lead to
335 many bytes awake you we have new
bounties we have new quests we have a
new story mission and we blighted
chalice strike and the winners were on
the strike
put the April update we've had the
opportunity to go back really retool a
fan favorite and the winners run strike
you're running through the strike with a
whole new set of enemies whole new set
of mechanics and a brand new boss
with the blighted chawla strike verax
has sensed a new taken power rising to
take the throne and he wants you to
chase this power and ultimately captured
malok to imprison him in the prison of
elders
we've updated the prison of elders with
three versions first we bumped up the
light level it's much more difficult now
we also have a full taken aided version
take a date it is when we go into an
area and we express artistically the
infestation of the taken and we have the
challenge road there are eight new
bosses that you can face and new
modifiers where the players must fight a
series of boxes three in a row every
week in order to complete their
scorecard and earn elite rewards with
the prison of elders we've made it so
you don't always require a key that
wasn't exactly something that players
enjoyed now you can go down to the big
chest as many times you want a week
with these new challenges come new
rewards including a new type of gear
called chroma in addition to shaders in
addition to mix matching their armor
they now have a new way to further
express the light in their Guardians
customize your entire appearance from
your armor to your weapons you will
literally glow with a color that's a
reflection of your personality and an
extension of your garden
many players were clamoring for to take
an appearance ever since we launched the
taken King so that's a whole new set of
armor that they can play with and really
look at a badass and doing that once you
collect a full set of taking armor for
one character you will be given the take
and emote for free the live team is
taking exotics from year one and
bringing them forward with all of the
increased levels of power that you would
expect bringing back a number of
familiar exotics and updating a variety
of your one legendaries shadow price
badger CCL there's two to the morgue ldr
all of those kinds of vanguard and
crucible weapons that players loved in
your one we're excited to give guardians
new bounties new strikes new quest lines
gear customization options you prison of
elders challenges more things to kill
more things to collect more things to do
there's just more of everything
you
I'm most excited about raising my light
level and then going out and acquire
some of that chroma gear and a pro them
taking the day off work too I am excited
the new taken sword is awesome you can
just go destroy the taken with their own
sword